okay guys it is the 23rd of January my
name is jess mcdonald and you're tuned
in to get [ __ ] first up after
confirming the witcher 3 won't be coming
to last gen CD Projekt RED have told us
exactly what they've been able to
achieve on current-gen the dev have said
that the witcher 3 comes fairly close to
maxing out the power of the ps4 and xbox
one sierra marcin a winski told idea who
doesn't think they've totally eclipsed
the power capacities with the consoles
but they've certainly gotten almost
everything they put out of them he said
that part of the reason why they've been
able to do this is because they largely
skipped the ps3 and 360 cycles and
devoted more time focusing on the ps4
and xbox one if CD Projekt RED had
decided to go ahead with making the game
for last gen or winsty said it's likely
they would have had to sacrifice half
their vision if you are still holding
out for this one we're looking at a
vague sometime in 2014 release window
next up Elder Scrolls online is not
going to be crap or if it is gonna be
crap at least it's gonna be crap that
sounds good with a-list celebrity voice
actors Bethesda have announced that
among the bevy of voice actors is Monty
Python's John Cleese Bill Nighy Kate
Beckinsale the dude who played
Dumbledore Doctor Octopus 1970s Wonder
Woman and Malcolm McDowell the kid from
the incomparable a clockwork orange and
obviously the voice actor cast also
includes Jennifer Hale because no one in
their right minds would make a game
without Jennifer Hale or nolan north in
it in use of weird Japanese things a
sexy car game on Vita has been censored
in the West because it's totally filthy
yep a filthy card game the English
version of monster monpiece is getting
tensed because the high level cards
consist of increasingly exposed anime
girls naturally in awkward things you
shouldn't ever do to your consoles
players can power up their cards by
vigorously rubbing either side of their
beta so even if you do find yourself
with the censored version at least you
can look forward to doing that on some
expecting murder public transport to
murder the definitive edition is a thing
that's happening and it's call of duty
ghosts all over again where the devils
begin in question tries to simmer down
the console war over frame rates we know
that the ps4 version is all set to run
at 60 frames per second but for some
reason square enix is staying
tight-lipped about what xbox one users
are going to get the company line from
Square Enix is presently both platforms
offer the same outstanding tomb raider
experience but dam is being the
competitive salt we are really want that
xbox one frame rate confirmation whether
you picked up sony or microsoft console
the dev have confirmed you will be
getting the 1080 experience and square
saying anything beyond 30 frames per
second will look awesome and it's all
good let me know if you think xbox one
users are missing out couldn't give a
damn about frame rates or just think
it's a little shady the square would
confirm the frame rate for one console
over the other you can leave me your
thoughts in the comments down below or
on my twitter where an at jeff mcdonald
that's all the good stuff i've got
thursday but tomorrow I'll have my top
five all wrapped up and ready to go so
come check back then assisi